Anish cannot be happy right now oh if I
I if this claim is accurate that would
be it's the correct claim hold on he
said Queen D5 is a three time repe it's
Queen it's Queen E6 if he's claiming
Queen D5 I think that might correct yeah
I see the queen on D5 I do too so Queen
SOA you're saying queen queen
E6 yeah I was pretty sure it was six so
Liam claims correctly but with the wrong
move so he's not going to be awarded we
should explain what really is going on
here the three-fold repetition a player
is allowed to claim a position but he
has to speak the move that he intended
to play I have never seen a three-time
repetition claim like this and it
continues valid Peter but it was the
wrong move yeah this is this is a first
for me as well after what we just saw
Yes I'm going to be heartbroken if this
actually ends badly for Liam